refugees being vaccinated for kovid 19
in the zaatari camp in jordan but this
the un secretary general told a meeting
of the security council
is the exception rather than the norm
progress on vaccinations has been widely
uneven
and unfair just 10 countries
have administrated 75 percent of alcove
19 vaccines
meanwhile more than 130 countries had
not received a single dose
and those affected by conflict and
insecurity are at particular risk
of being left behind the current
president of the council the uk
is proposing a new resolution calling
for ceasefires in conflicts around the
world
so that vaccines can be administered and
by calling for vaccination sea spas and
by calling for
covert 19 vaccination plans to include
all high-risk populations including
refugees
this resolution and this council really
has an opportunity
to help get vaccines distributed
to the most vulnerable communities
across the planet
both the state councillor of china and
the u.s
secretary of state took part in the
meeting both stressed the need for
global solidarity
even though there's still real tension
between the two nations
this perhaps an indication that it won't
further stall global efforts on kovid
19.
the un secretary general is now calling
for a global vaccination plan he
believes the g20
is the best body to finance this and
he's calling on the g7 leaders who meet
on friday
to kick start this process james bay's
al jazeera
at the united nations